Most eyes and attention this
week were on the missile
that landed in Poland
just over the border
from Ukraine on Tuesday.
But the United States
does not believe
that Russia fired that missile.
What we all should have been
paying attention
to was the devastating
aerial bombardment of Ukraine
that Moscow delivered this week.
The British Ministry of Defense said
Tuesday saw likely
the largest number of strikes
that Russia has conducted in a single day
since the first week of the invasion.
One of the main targets
has been energy
infrastructure,
plunging swathes of Ukraine
into darkness.
The capital,
Kiev, experienced both blackouts
and communication disruptions
All this as winter cold
and snow have arrived.
Let me bring in the panel
to talk about Ukraine,
and we will later get to China.
I have two terrific guests
joining me in studio,
Richard Haass and Tim Naftali.
Richard is, of course,
the president of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
And Tim is a CNN presidential
historian and teaches history at NYU.
So that
bombardment just
you know,
this is part of the new general
who's been put in place in Russia
This is the guy who oversaw
the Syrian campaign.
This is exactly what he did in Syria.
It is brutal.
I mean, he is
and they are going for
energy infrastructure
they're basically plunging
the civilian population
into cold and misery. Right.
Can Ukraine
just keep taking these body blows?
Look, you're exactly right.
This is the Aleppo ization
of the Ukraine war.
Russia can't compete,
if you will,
on the traditional battlefield.
So they're saying
this is our battlefield.
We are going to
so increase
the misery
that we are going to try
to get you to shout uncle
and to come to the negotiating table
and give us enough so we can claim
this was all worth it.
History suggests not.
You know,
the history of mass bombing during World
War Two,
it tends to stiffen
the spine of civilian populations.
But we'll see.
It's part of Putin's larger
strategy to play for time.
He's hoping the new House
of Representatives
here might give him a break,
is hoping Europeans get cold this winter.
Maybe they'll lose some of their spirit
of backing Ukraine.
And obviously, he wants to break the back
back of the Ukrainian people.
I don't think it will work,
but that right now is his strategy.
Do you agree with that?
Oh, it's absolutely his strategy.
He is looking for weakness.
He is looking for a lack of resolve
on the part of Europeans
and the United States.
And like all autocrats,
he underestimates democracy.
Says one thing
you can count on from an autocrat.
They think we are weak
and they always get surprised
when we don't back down.
So we have to do is project to them
a sense of unity and resolve,
which we have so far been able to do.
We have actually remarkably so.
Europeans and the United States
have continued to tell Putin
and to send signals
to Putin
that we mean it
when we want to defend
Ukrainian sovereignty.
But it does highlight.
Ukraine is going to be
devastated I don't know
whether you could even come up
with a figure
that would describe
what the rebuilding of Ukraine
is going to cost at this stage.
It's incalculable.
It'll look,
they this polarization
and this is a modern society.
You and I have both spent time
there even recently.
And you go down to downtown Kiev
and you could have been
in any city in modern
you know, any modern city
in Europe and contemporary Europe.
The cost of this, the human cost order,
like a quarter of the population
more has been displaced.
The physical cost now
I spoke to a friend
the other day in Kiev.
I think she's in a 20 a
she on the 23rd floor of her building.
The only way to get to her
apartment is to walk up
and down the stairs.
Imagine what this is like for the elderly
and for four young children.
So this is you know,
this is a conscious strategy.
It is it is brutal.
These are war crimes. On an hourly basis.
That is what we are
seeing in the cost of rebuilding Ukraine.
The years
it will take, the dollars
it will take will be enormous.
To me,
you had a really fascinating piece
in Foreign Affairs
in which you pointed out
that Putin is in a conference
with a bunch of Russian journalists.
In answer to to one of his favorite
foreign policy experts.
McAnuff, who's been on the show.
The guy asked him about the Cuban
Missile Crisis and what did he say?
Kind of asked Putin,
are you going to be like Khrushchev
accepting a retreat?
And Putin actually it was even better.
He said,
are you going to be like
Khrushchev and Khrushchev?
And Putin says,
you mean accept a retreat? No.
He characterized
what Khrushchev did as a retreat.
And what's so important, I think, is that
there is a sense among American
and some European elites
that the Cuban missile crisis
ended peacefully
because of statesmanship. On both sides.
There is no doubt
that statesmanship mattered,
but the initial move towards an offramp
was from the Russian the Soviet side.
The Russians were scared
And the reason they were scared
was that they were looking
for some lack of resolve
on the part of John F Kennedy,
and they didn't see it.
And when John F Kennedy
imposed a blockade
and stuck by it, Khrushchev realized,
I don't want war.
I've got to find an off ramp.
So what I was trying to share
was don't look to history
to give you a reason to go to Putin.
And give him an off ramp.
If anything, it's the opposite.
Don't give Putin up a sense
that you want to end this
because he's looking for that.
He's desperate for straws.
Force him to want an off ramp.
The way that John F Kennedy
forced Khrushchev to seek an off ramp
from the Cuban Missile Crisis.
That's it would agree.
But I would actually say Khrushchev
probably acted under slightly
greater constraint than Putin is now.
There was a degree of institutions
in the Soviet Union need.
It was sclerotic.
You had a degree
of collective leadership.
We have a personalization
and a de-institutionalization
of that country,
which makes it frightening
that one man has so much power.
But do you agree with him?
Which I think is right,
which is
we shouldn't
be searching for off ramps for Putin.
We should be maintaining pressure.
Let him search for the off ramp.
Absolutely.
And, you know,
the situation is is far from being ripe
for diplomacy.
Neither side right now
is prepared to to accept half a loaf.
What we want to do
is create the conditions for diplomacy
rather than go directly into diplomacy.
All right.